hello nurses i'm rob and i am jess
and i'm maurice and we are the voice
cast of animaniacs
with new episodes streaming on hulu
right now and what are we going to do
tonight
same thing we do every night pinky
challenge the draw of gang
to draw us from memory yes
today you'll be drawing the cast of the
animaniacs
from memory oh my god
i've never tried them that's very
difficult
yeah i've actually never drawn them
before even though i grew up on the show
so we're doing so we're doing everyone
the five of you
will each be tasked with one of the five
characters yakko
wacko dot pinky and the brain oh wow
okay oh boy okay who wants to do what
i think i can do the brain i'll do yakko
i'll do wacko
i'll do dot i get pinky of course i get
pinky okay
i get the dumb one great thanks guys
all right so we ready to do this yeah
yeah
let's all try to draw the animatics on
the same campus
oh my god nice okay
we should be able to help other people
out right all right brent
i'm just gonna draw and then we can
resize our sketches appropriately
mine's the one that wears pants yes
that's what that's why i chose this one
because it's the only thing i can
remember about him
and i don't think he's wearing shoes
right he just has his like
dog feet right so we just have dogs i
don't think they wear
shoes so the bottom half of mine is
about perfect right now
um oh my god what
oh my gosh how did you do that i'm i'm
guessing man
i don't know what i'm doing right austin
jeez man
[Music]
this is so good this is great i'm
getting a dog vibe
right is this a dog character yeah i
think they're
they're like uh like rubber hose looking
kind of
dogs rubber hose dogs
i think they're technically not anything
i think they're like
old you know what i mean like those old
19 20s animation characters
are they wearing gloves yeah i do know
they wear gloves
yeah okay guys mine is looking
like scooby-doo um yeah
what do i do is look like give me
oh geez okay yeah steph help me out more
like
maybe something like that gotcha thank
you
kyra what's that like you guys all
nailed this okay you guys have been
drawing this guy for years now i haven't
i've never
i've never drawn the animation you guys
are hustling me
you're hustling me i literally never
dropped these characters
i've never drawn them i don't even think
i've seen a full episode
really yeah how is that possible because
it was like
before my time you're kidding me it's
just
a bunch of like 90s bill clinton
references doesn't it
it's true yeah it does oh you all are
making me feel
very old right now you can evan's old
cabin don't don't don't
i've seen wacko's wish okay
that's good that's the only one i've
seen
what what stop it brent
that's how you know what i'm laughing at
it's very good
do you all know why dot's name is dot
no no because because there's the warner
brothers
yeah and then the dot in the brothers
symbol does that make sense
yeah y'all get it okay guys mine
looks awful help me out just help me out
here uh i think
i think his nose comes out yeah oh his
nose like comes out maybe more of a
more of the nose up here okay okay
gotcha thank you like what is what is
this thing this isn't good
it's orange what you're making is art no
you gotta help me out dude this is why
we're doing this
like one campus thing right i know the
warners are like
they have this like thing with their
ears that do like this thing
oh you're right yeah yeah yeah there are
basic shape is like this
with like these hair things at the side
oh yeah they have this like
disney like like black
fur thing and like a flesh face
right yeah i remember yeah yeah
oh you're so good at this oh my wacko
looks so good now
you did it teamwork man makes the dream
twerk oh oh i remembered something with
brain i remember telling a brain
all right his eye things he's got the
same eye things
they're like really big on his face they
look like that
wait what brain's got like
the big he's got these on his head
that makes sense i am missing that
detail thank you
oh wait a minute nope that's a goofy
snout i can't do a goofy snout
are his ears pointier are they like that
i feel like i don't think they're
pointy brent stop going around and
fixing other people's drawings i'm
utilizing the potential of this
new internet medium or you could work on
a background
that's true meanwhile kira in the corner
just quietly killing it
like trying to think and be like am i
drawing these hands correctly
all right colors colors talk to me about
colors
i believe they're both white okay
uh blue eyes
blue eyes uh
pink nose pink or red nose
i think i'm i'm going with the pink nose
i think they do have red noses that's a
good point they have red noses they do
yeah they're like little yeah clown
noses i drew you a nice background there
you go
thank you bro i think i have to test
something though
does pinky look like kevin
stop it
i think i think kevin might have just
drawn himself again
ladies and gentlemen i don't know
there is influence that's uncanny the
similarities
[Music]
i think i've cracked this case
[Music]
oh thank you oh my god kira
what the hell guys mine doesn't look
right
what am i doing wrong besides everything
oh stop
is this is this what the show is going
to be now now that jackie's not here you
all just
gang up on me draw your quickest stephen
snowbird
all right three two one go here we go
[Music]
oh he's got he's got glasses i know that
much
there it's steven spielberg he's
directing a movie
yes all of us love it he's pointing at
it
[Music]
there he is love it okay
guys i need an eye color and a nose
color and then i'm done
uh yellow for the eyes
green for the nose
wait a minute wait a minute i think he's
a green mouse right
he's like green fur knock it off he's
like he's like
neon green just the bullying kevin owens
stop it guys guys you're so mean
okay friends i think we should try and
put this together into some kind of
cohesive
composition what do you think all right
i'm giving us a shadow
oh drop shots
all right friends pen's down i think we
did it
yes what's uh how do we think we did
we all like um collectively shared the
same brain cell
well i think we did great i'm really
proud of yeah we got really close
yeah we really did yeah i'd watch this
version of the show
yes now that the drawing is finished
there's only one thing
left to do and that's send it over to
the voice cast of the animaniacs to see
what they do
you can't just pull that out you can't
just do that
guys i'm literally shaking
wow holy [ __ ] look at that
wow now first off i gotta say i love any
drawing where i'm riding a rocket so
well done
yeah you look like you're uh slim
pickings and doctor strangelove wacko
europe
[Laughter]
you look excellent brain i look like
i've had a few too many of those totina
pizza rolls
instead of food pellets i gotta say
stephanie has
has captured brains uh deeply ingrained
oh my gosh
dude stephanie stephanie killed it yeah
you've got
you've got uh brain down and austin can
i call you daddy because that's a great
yeah he did a great and
and look look what uh kyra did her kira
with doc
she she got to fight it yeah by the
cuteness
right it's like we she's totally got but
she's got just enough of that anime vibe
that's
very cool i was thinking the same thing
it's a hybrid it's really really good
yeah yeah and look at mr spielberg and
the right looks like speedy alka seltzer
with a beard
how's that for a hip cultural record
it's great man good job everybody
outstanding hey you guys when you get a
job think of us because we need to work
yeah come on draw some new stuff so we
can get voices on it we're all gabascan
doesn't by itself
we're better look at these drawings and
more drawings from the draw-off crew
be sure to check us out on instagram and
twitter after off show
and we'll see you next time